hi everyone my name is Tamara chambers
and this is Tamara's never seen and
today I am watching speed so I have some
crazy 90s curly Sandra Bullock bangs
going on I always thought that speed was
that movie crash I want to say I had a
bunch of different stories going on
crash I want to say no not crash what am
I thinking have I know that Joss Whedon
is said to have kind of like ghosts
written the script she came in and like
pumped up some of the dialogue but a lot
of people say that he kind of just like
did the script since this Sandra
Bullock's first role ever to like first
big role demolition man came out first
thanks Internet just kidding okay I'm
not gonna stall any more with facts that
I don't actually know just getting from
Google great let's do it okay
[Music]
you
okay I just have one question was that
the best movie ever made or the very
best movie ever made thank you action
Gods Thor up there thank you are we
kidding ourselves I should have seen
this the second that I was conceived I
know I was conceived in 1991 but still
three years late put cryogenics I don't
care that it's rated R whatever listen
the opening credits are spanning down a
very very very long elevator shaft in a
very very very tall building this credit
sequence is long y'all long for a movie
that's only like an hour and a half it
really packs a punch in the amount of
action that you get starting off I was
just kind of like oh no so we see Dennis
Hopper pretending to be a maintenance
worker in the building that the elevator
is located and he's gonna have this
hostage situation kind of deal going on
just Dennis Hopper and all over the
place someone from the building comes up
to him and is like hey you're not
allowed to be here and he's like no yeah
I am the guys like well I need to see a
work order and Dennis Hopper very
unspeaking is like okay sure
here it is surprise oh but Dennis it was
not a surprise
so the hostage situation takes place and
we see Keanu Reeves and the guy from
Dumb and Dumber Jeff Daniel flying
through the air at landing right in
front of the building here's a fun thing
though I I was watching with my I
thought that Jeff Daniels was Joey
Gladstone from Full House Dave Coulier I
thought that that was that actor yes
I've seen Dumb and Dumber I know that
Jeff Daniels isn't dumb and Dumberer yes
I would say that I'm probably out of the
to dumber so just you know as a warning
there's a lot of cut it out jokes in
here from Joey Gladstone you think I
just search things while watching I made
enough of these mistakes so you'd think
I would make sure I knew what I was
talking about by like really going hard
on the cut in out jokes but no but no
holy shit is that cut it out
Joey Gladstone no it's not timorous it's
not him so they fly in just the coolest
shot of them coming up in their car over
this hill and getting massive air and
then landing and then running in and
they find out that there's bonds on the
elevator and they're trying to get these
people out of the elevator and there's
that weird crazy scary instance where
the elevator is like halfway in between
this elevator shaft until they're
crawling out but you're like is it gonna
fall and chop their legs off who knows
tensions are high stakes are high lots
of butts in peril here lots of butts in
peril now they're trying to find hopper
because he's trying to escape
after the bomb plan went sour he honors
slides down some cables and Joey
Gladstone gives him a disapproving look
and I just want him to say cut it out
soap
dumb now I really really really want to
see a remake where Joey Gladstone is in
it like this will never happen you know
it's hard to be me sometimes carrying
the weight of the world on my shoulder
hopper has Jeff Daniels Keano shoots
Jeff Daniels in the leg he falls and
then hopper does the most amazing
maniacal laugh I've ever heard and then
shuts the door and then his explosions
go off so then you're like oh man hopper
just realized he could never laugh as
evilly as he just laughed so we might as
well descended that's what you think
this is the best movie I've ever seen
okay I don't I can't I can't do it
there's no way I would do it justice but
that didn't remind me I've been playing
Mario Party on switch and there's one
character like ooh something like that
and he steals stars and coins for people
and he's got the best best best vocal
cue ever when you tell him to steal
something he goes ha ha ha ha yeah I
found out by searching the internet that
in the first version of the script
Dennis Hopper actually does die and then
when he comes back you think it's him
the whole time turns out his Jeff
Daniels character and then they decided
against that just didn't really read
what read white read right to Jeff
Daniels character was just so likable
and like they were such a good partner
and it just yeah won't work but Dennis
Hopper his back decided to blow up a bus
and then was like I'm actually gonna
blow up another bus and of course this
is where Sandra Bullock's character is
introduced and she's on the bus and that
buzzes gon blow live good thing she's a
cop nope Ragna
you all know this I'm just gonna say it
anyways the whole thing is that the bus
if it reaches 50 miles an hour it cannot
go below 50 miles an hour 50 miles an
hour turns on the bomb activates the
bomb and then once it reaches under 50
well then it explodes it gets all
floating there in LA which that's
impossible
traffic in LA is so so bad I've been in
LA traffic so badly that I got out of
the car and I did some stretches on the
road because we were sitting for like a
half-hour and stands still traffic it's
just there's just no way and I love they
do address it to a certain extent she
goes off into the lip and like is hating
all these cars and like could she was
sustained above fifty miles an hour
which is amazing the driving looks so
cool in this at some points it maybe
seems like they're not going at exactly
50 miles an hour you know like it seems
a little slower at times but for the
most part it looks killer
some bad guy on the bus is like oh shit
there's a cop here now I guess I'll
shoot him pulls out a gun and cameras
like I'm not here for you man I'm here
for the betterment of the world okay I'm
Keanu Reeves I do incredible things I
don't know if you've seen reddit but I'm
great and then the bad guy accidentally
shoots the bus driver shoulder and then
Sandra Bullock takes over and I love
that she takes over she doesn't have a
license it got revoked for speeding
hilarious there's enough c4 on this
thing to blow a hole in the world this
is better than video games it's better
than Disneyland it's better than Mars
cheese castle it's better than taking an
incredible nap this movie rules there's
a point where Sandra Bullock runs into a
baby stroller and it's tensions are high
she starts freaking out you think she
hit a baby then then explodes with a
bunch of cans and everyone just a
collective sigh it's taken I know I was
watching it with one other person but I
feel like the whole world was like you I
also I liked the romance and I do not
think that this needs to be a romantic
movie I also found out while searching
the internet that Sandra Bullock was
initially supposed to be kind of like a
funny side character they were thinking
about having Ellen DeGeneres as this
role and I think that would have been
fun too but I don't mind the romance cuz
it's so much fun and even their
chemistry owing the things like that
great but they're both so wonderful and
it's just so cheesy and fun then I don't
I don't want it at all
I actually pretty I love it obviously I
love it holy shit are they about to jump
a bus over a 50-foot gap in freeway are
they this movie is a gift so much fun
they drive off the freeway into an
airports they have a ton of room on the
runway and then he goes under the bus
and he starts trying to disarm the bomb
and then his friend Jeff Daniels is like
oh shit we know who this guy is he's an
ex-cop we're gonna go get him
hold tight and then he's like cuckoo
I'll hold tight under this bus oh shit
now I'm falling off the bus let me grab
on with my knife hits the gas tank
they're leaking gas he's like I think we
got 10 minutes left the gas tank is
going like this like super fast like I
really think you got 10 you don't have
10 minutes but and then Jeff Daniels
dies because he is in the house and it's
a decoy and he blows up this guy likes
he really he loves c4 this scene where
Jeff Daniels dies he sees him like
exploding out the window of this home if
they think that Dennis Hopper is it just
referred as he's exploding out of the
window he should have just been like I
really went in all all the way with the
cut it out stuff I'm sorry
while they're evacuating though they
have to keep it above 50 miles an hour
still and so everyone's evacuated except
for Sandra and Keanu and they escape
from this like little hatch in the bus
they slide out on a piece of wood and
they're all intertwined together and
then they can't send it or no they don't
kiss yet the kiss later lots of kissing
happens it's amazing the escape is so
exciting and then the bus runs into a
plane it's got to be a lot of the budget
then Dennis Hopper get Sandra Bullock
and escapes through a little ninja
turtle hole in the ground I wrote how
much people or does this dude have cuz
it's more than a little there on this
runaway train now and
the most unrealistic thing about this
entire film is all of the reliable
public transportation that la is like
shown to have had because that's not
true he gets Dennis Hopper he saves
Sandra they kiss is it the greatest
movie ever made absolutely did this pave
the way for action 100% do I want to
kiss both Keanu Reeves and Sandra
Bullock while they're kissing each other
definitely let's make it let's put it in
my schedule somewhere
I just wrote okie on oh I love your way
on the trains I was thinking that I
would sing it half of the things that I
write down just definitely do not come
out of my mouth for these reactions
because they're so stupid but while I'm
watching it like go go go
[Music]
I hear speed two is pretty bad should I
not watch it or should I watch it I have
a ton of really good films coming up and
then in March I am doing mom month
because I've never seen Goodfellas I've
never seen Godfather one I've never seen
Godfather - I've never seen Scarface
thank you so much for watching I will
see you all next week
[Music]
[Applause]
you